The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Well, we
are in the middle
of something really interesting.
We are talking about squeezing.
We are talking about
non classical light.
And today, I sort of
want to wrap it up.
And I think it will really
be an exciting class.
But before I continue
with the material,
I want to address a question,
which actually came up
in discussions with
several of the students.
And this is, I realize
that some people said, OK.
Everything makes sense.
But what are we plotting?
What is really squeezed?
Are we squeezing in
the spatial domain?
the temporal domain?
So the plots look wonderful,
with these ellipses
and the circles.
But, what is it really
we are doing here?
So let me address that.
First of all, we are talking
about a single harmonic
oscillator.
We showed that the
[INAUDIBLE] equations
can be reduced to a bunch of
harmonic oscillator equations.
One for each mode.
And now we are
talking, today and
in the previous few classes,
about one single mode,
about one harmonic oscillator.
And the harmonic oscillator
has canonically variables
of momentum and position.
But this is just to make
a connection for you
with something you have learned.
What we are talking about is
a single harmonic oscillator,
which is one single mode of
the electromagnetic field.
So maybe let me draw
a cartoon for that.
So let's assume
we have a cavity.
We have an electromagnetic wave.
There is propagation,
where it's e to the ikz.
There is transverse confinement.
Maybe there is a
Gaussian e to the minus
x squared plus y squared over
sum [INAUDIBLE] parameter.
All of that is simply
the spatial mode.
And we just take that for
given because we're not
solving the spatial
differential equation.
All we are doing is we are
looking at this one mode.
And the two degrees
of freedom is
that this mode can have a
certain number of photons.
It's the amplitude.
And the second one is you
can see the temporal phase.
It can be a cosine omega t.
it can be a sine omega t.
It can be a superposition.
But whatever we are talking
about is in this mode.
There is nothing happening
in the spatial domain.
They're just asking, what is
the oscillation in this mode?
The whole mode does
what it should.
It has a prefect, of
which is the amplitude.
And it has a temporal effect
of which we factor out.
And this is what we
are talking about.
Let me be a little
bit more specific
and say, that when we
are plotting things,
we are plotting the Q
representation, the phase space
representation of the
statistical operator,
which is simply describing
this single mode
of the harmonic oscillator.
And by performing the
diagram matrix elements,
we obtain the Q distribution.
In that case, we
have the vacuum.
We have a displaced vacuum,
which is in coherent state.
And our x's are, from
the very definition,
in the complex plane
with a real part
of the imaginary part of alpha.
However, we can also
define [? the  Veetner ?]
distribution, which is another
phase based distribution.
It's almost the same
as the Q distribution.
It's just this little
bit smeared out
by h bar because of
some commutators.
But nothing you
have to worry about.
In that case, the
projection of the W function
on the vertical
axis, on the y-axis,
is the momentum wave
function squared.
On the x-axis, it is the
spatial wave function
squared of the
harmonic oscillator.
So therefore, we
may sometimes think,
when we have a distribution
here, we project it.
And we see what is the
momentum distribution.
Or what is the
spatial distribution
of the mechanical
harmonic oscillator.
Which is analogous,
which is equivalent,
to the one mode of the
electromagnetic field
we are using.
I know it may help
you to some extent
to think about the P and Q.
But it may also be misleading
because it gives you the
impression something is moving
with a momentum
P, in real space.
Let me therefore
emphasize what are
the normalized forms of P and Q.
If I do the symmetric and
anti-symmetric combination
of the annihilation
and creation operator,
I over squared root 2.
I call those a1 and a2.
And they are nothing
else than Q and P
normalized by the characteristic
momentum of spatial coordinates
of the harmonic oscillator.
So what is important
here is that a1 and a2--
forget about P,Q now.
They are equivalent.
But for the
electromagnetic field,
a1 and a2 have a very
direct interpretation.
They are called the two
quadrature operators.
And what I mean by
that becomes clear
when I use the
Heisenberg representation
for the electric field.
And I'm here using
the formula which
is given in the book of
Weissbluth, in page 175.
Some pages copied
from this book have
been posted on the website.
So we have our
normalization factor,
which is related to the electric
field of a single photon.
We have the polarization factor.
But now we have an
expression which
involves the quadrature
operators, a1 and a2.
Just to be specific, we
are not in a cavity here.
Therefore, we have propagating
waves cosine (kr) sine (kr).
But you can also immediately
use a similar expression
for the case of a cavity.
Let us specify that r equals 0.
And then we realize what the
two quadrature operators are.
a2 is the operator which
creates and annihilates
an electromagnetic
field, so to speak,
photons, which have
an electric field.
Which oscillates
as cosine omega t.
And a1 is the quadrature
operator for the sine omega t
component.
So therefore, if you simply
analyze the electric field,
what is cosine omega 2 is
related to the a2 quadrature
operator.
The sine omega 2 oscillation
is related to the a1 quadrature
operator.
So life would be
easier, but more boring,
if you could create a
pure cosine, or pure sine
oscillation of the
electromagnetic field.
But you can't because a1
and a2 do not commute.
And there is an
uncertainty relation
that delta a1 times delta a2
is larger or equal to 1/2.
And we have the equal sign
for coherent states alpha.
So therefore, if we look
at the electric field,
you know, everything
moves around
periodically in r because
it's a traveling wave and t
because it's an
oscillating wave.
So let's not confuse things
with simply peak r equals 0.
We've already done that.
But now let's peak t equals 0.
That t equals 0.
The sine omega t is 0.
And therefore, the distribution
for a2, the expectation value,
and the variance for the
quadrature operator, a2,
can be simply read off by
looking at the electric field.
So, in other words,
at t equals 0,
the electric field,
which is obtained
by projecting our quasi
probabilities on the y-axis,
gives the expectation
value for a1
and the variant,
delta a1 squared.
Somebody says 2.
That t equals 0.
Yes.
And now, if you want to see what
the other quadrature component
is, well.
We just wait a quarter period
until the sine, which was 0,
is maximum.
And the cosine omega t is 0.
So therefore, it's
pi over 2 omega,
using the projection on
the y-axis, gives us a1.
And delta a1 squared.
Or, alternatively, we
don't need to wait.
We can do t equals 0.
And we can project
onto the x-axis.
Let me just throw few
things into this diagram.
If you had a classical
motion, which
would simply be cosine omega t.
Then that would mean, if
you had a motion which
where only cosine
omega t-- yes, it
would be a point on the y-axis.
However, classically
we can never
have something which
is just cosine omega t.
The point has to
blurred into a circle.
This is the coherent state.
So this coherent state has
now-- let me just call it 1,
for the sake of the
argument-- the point
would be the
classical oscillator.
It is just cosine omega t.
Everything is deterministic.
No uncertainty.
No nothing.
Of course, it means that
the time of evolution,
it goes in a circle.
But this is what everything
does in an harmonic oscillator
when time evolves into the
e to the i omega t factor.
So let's not get
confused with it.
Let's just look at t equals 0.
And we input [INAUDIBLE]
if r equals 0,
the classical
oscillator is one point.
But now, we have a spread here.
This says that trying
to mechanically
the amplitude of the
cosine omega t term
is not entirely false.
It's not [INAUDIBLE] sharp.
There are fluctuations.
And in addition, we have
ellipse in this direction,
which we project
onto the x-axis.
And this tells us what the
distribution in our ensemble,
in our kind of
mechanical ensemble,
is for the amplitudes of
the sine omega t motion.
So the best we can do
is try to mechanically--
if you want to have something,
which is really just cosine
omega t.
We have to squeeze it, that the
cosine omega t amplitude is now
extremely sharp.
But the sine omega t
amplitude in the ensemble
is completely smeared out.
So this is what
we're talking about.
Now, what I think has
confused some of you
is what I thought was
a wonderful example.
The classical
squeezing experiment.
I mean, these are visuals which
will be in your head forever,
when you saw Professor
Pritchard with a circle pendulum
he's just pulling.
And then the circle
squeezes into an ellipse.
And it seems that something
here is squeezed in real space.
But this is actually wrong.
But how you should have
looked at the experiment,
and I made a comment
about it, but maybe not
emphatically enough.
You should have really thought
about a single pendulum.
And this single pendulum, if
it has an [INAUDIBLE] phase,
is in a superposition of sine
omega t and cosine omega t.
And if you pull on the string,
if you shorten and lengthen
the pendulum, it's
sine 2 omega t.
You will amplify the prefactor
in front of sine omega t.
And you will exponentially
de-amplify the factor
in front of cosine omega t.
So therefore, what will happen
if this pendulum oscillates--
and let me say with a phase,
well, sine omega t plus delta,
if delta is 90 degrees.
Cosine if delta is 0.
It's sine.
And let's say this pendulum
oscillates at 45 degrees.
Sine omega t plus 45 degrees.
If you now parametrically
derive it with squeezing action,
it would now mean
that you, let's
just make it a sine convention.
You de-amplify the cosine.
You amplify the sine.
And after a while, instead of
oscillating with sine omega
t plus 45 degrees,
it will oscillate
with an amplified
amplitude at sine omega t.
This is what you have done.
And this is a
mechanical analogy.
There is, of course,
no squeezing in any way
because in a
classical pendulum, we
start with one definite value.
If you prepare the system well.
And then, we just
change the motion.
We amplify.
We pick out a phase and
that's what we are doing.
Now the true ways how classical
squeezing can come in.
One it is if the motion of
the pendulum is-- maybe there
is an uncertainty.
Maybe Professor Pritchard did
experiments with an ion trap.
And actually, 20 years
ago, he published
a [INAUDIBLE] [? letter ?]
on classic squeezing.
And you think, how
can you publish
[INAUDIBLE] [? letter ?]
on classical squeezing?
Well, he had developed the
world's most accurate ion trap,
measuring atomic masses with
10 and 11 digit positions.
And what was actually
one limiting factor
was for Kelvin, the
thermal distribution
of harmonic oscillator modes.
And so, he didn't have
just one clean amplitude.
The sine omega t
amplitudes had a spread
because of the thermal
distribution he started from.
And so what he then did is,
by simply classical squeezing
by doing classically
with the ion trap
exactly what he did with the
pendulum, derive sine 2 omega
t, he could now take this
classic distribution.
This is a classic distribution.
In one axis, it's a
distribution of amplitudes
of the cosine motion.
And here it's the
classic distribution
of the amplitudes
of the sine motion.
And he was squeezing
it into this direction.
So he had a narrower
definition of the coefficient
for the cosine omega t motion.
And as I will tell
you today, you
can now do a
homodyne measurement,
which is reducing the noise.
So essentially, he prepared,
quote unquote "Effectively
a [? code ?] ensemble by
squeezing the uncertainty
in the cosine prefactor."
Or at the expense of
increasing the prefactor,
the uncertainty, the variance,
in prefactor of the sine omega
t motion.
Finally, you all saw
something visually.
You saw how a circular motion
became a linear motion.
So what was going on here?
Well, I mentioned to you that
the circular pendulum actually
has two modes.
These are two modes of
the harmonic oscillator.
And I'm not talking
about two modes
of the harmonic oscillator.
Everything we're discussing
here is about one mode
of the harmonic oscillator.
The circular motion
of the pendulum
was just a nice
visualization trick
that, if the pendulum
moves in a circle,
you have a degenerate
harmonic oscillator.
One is excited
with sine omega t.
The other one is excited
with cosine omega t.
And instead of doing
two experiments,
if you would start
with sine omega t,
and you parametrically
drive it, you amplified it.
If you start with
cosine omega t,
you could bring the
pendulum to a stop.
But instead of doing
two experiments,
Professor Pritchard
just did one.
And he showed that the sine
omega t motions became larger.
And the orthogonal cosine
omega t motion shrank.
And therefore, you saw that
the circular motion, which
was a superposition
of sine and cosine,
became [? pure ?] sine motion.
But the fact that
there was something
we could see in
the spatial domain
was simply due to the fact that
we had two experiments in one.
Two versions of the same
harmonic oscillator,
one in x and one in y.
And then, when we
did the experiment,
we saw something visually
in the spatial domain.
So that's why we saw squeezing
But you should really
think about it.
What the whole
action is, is it's
an interplay of de-amplifying
prefactors of cosine amplifying
prefactors of sine.
And if the prefactor
has a distribution,
by de-amplifying
it, you also shrink
the reach of the distribution.
And this is what
we call squeezing.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Stupid question.
So the operators, a1
and a2 here, right?
You use those instead of a and
a dagger because you use cosine
and sine rather than
[? e  to the i omega t ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
Because they should
contain [INAUDIBLE], right?
PROFESSOR: Let me go
back to the definition.
They are actually exactly
they correspond exactly
to position and momentum of the
mechanical harmonic oscillator.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
That makes sense.
Another thing is,
technically speaking,
we could call the
[? Basco ?] electric field
e cos kr minus omega
t as maximum squeezed
if we only had the
cos components?
PROFESSOR: Well,
not if I use it--
it depends how I
define squeezing.
So you would now
give a definition
of squeezing which says
that the variance in a1
is now unequal to
the variance in a2.
So the classical
oscillator is the point.
It has 0 variance in a1.
0 variance in a2.
But as I said, you can
actually apply all the way
to a classical
oscillator if you add
technical noise
or thermal noise.
Then your system is prepared,
not with a sharp value,
but with a distribution
which is simply
may be [? false ?] distribution,
due to the preparation.
So recall, it's
squeezing when the noise
in the amplitude
of the sine motion
is not equal to the noise in the
amplitude of the cosine motion.
Some people say, if it's
a little bit narrower,
they apply squeezing
to the situation
that we are uncertainty limited.
And then we squeeze.
But of course, you can always
reduce the noise in your system
by just preparing the system.
By cooling the system.
By selecting the system for
measurements, until you reach
the quantum limit.
So you can get a smaller
delta a1, a smaller delta a2,
without squeezing, just
better preparation.
Or by selecting your ensemble.
So squeezing in a narrower
sense only makes sense
when you hit the limit of what
quantum mechanics allows you.
And now you want to distribute
the variance unequally
between a1 and a2
because then you
can get something in
delta a1 or delta a2.
Which is better then
1 over square root 2.
And this is now really
quantum mechanically squeezed.
But they're both definitions.
Classical squeezing exists.
It's just not as common as
quantum mechanical squeezing.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I remember
that you said
that in the classical
squeezing, you
are attenuating one amplitude.
And you were amplifying
the other amplitude.
So, in this picture
then, shouldn't we
have the ellipse come down
from the circle on the y-axis?
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] not
just changing delta a,
but also changing b [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let me just
get a sketch up here.
So this is a2.
This is a1.
a2 is for the cosine omega t.
And a1 for the sine omega t.
So just to be specific.
So you want to prepare an
harmonic oscillator, which
is just sine omega t.
This is a point here.
If we are now parametrically--
so this has a value at t
equals 0.
Our a1 is not.
So if you are now squeezing your
classical harmonic oscillator,
you would have a situation
where a1 of t is s
naught times e to the plus
or minus t, depending on
whether you do the parametric
[? drive ?] at sine 2 omega
t or cosine 2 omega t.
So therefore, what
would happen is
this point will be amplified.
That would mean it would
just move out on the x-axis.
So this would be
for the plus sign.
Or, for the other case, you
would damp the motion to 0.
And this is a minus sign here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you were also
saying the variance--
PROFESSOR: A point
does not have variance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if you
want to build a variance,
you need, let's
say, three points.
One is the average value.
One is the left outlier.
One is the right outlier.
And what happens is now,
as you amplify the motion,
you would also amplify,
magnify the distance
between the points.
And if you de-amplify
it with a minus sign,
the distance between
the points would
shrink because all the
three points converged to 0.
So pretty much what
I just told you
for the three point ensemble.
You can now use it and construct
any initial condition you want.
And see what happens
due to squeezing.
Other questions?
Good.
So the question now is,
how to measure squeezing.
How to take advantage
of squeezing.
So the situation we are
facing is the following.
Let's assume we have done
a nice squeezing job.
And that means that
we have a sharp value.
We have created a
narrow distribution
of the cosign omega
2 coefficients.
So the cosine omega 2
motion is rather sharp.
But we also know that
the electric field itself
is sharp at this moment.
But since this ellipse
rotates, the electric field
will have enormous uncertainty
a [INAUDIBLE] period later.
So if we want to take
advantage that we have squeezed
the electromagnetic
field, they are now
a couple of ideas
which we can use.
One is we could just
measure the electric fields
stroboscopically.
We would just make
a setup, where
we look at this system
in a [INAUDIBLE]
measurement process.
Only, we only measure
the electric field
when the ellipse is like
this or is like this.
And therefore, we have a sharp
value of the electric field.
But instead of doing a
stroboscopic measurement,
we can do something else.
Remember, we have a
distribution of cosine omega t
and sine omega t.
And we have a distribution
of co efficiency and s.
And we know we are interested
in the cosine omega t.
So how to pick that
out has actually
been solved in
early [? radius ?].
You do a homodyne detection.
In other words, you take
a reference oscillator,
which is strong.
B of t is b naught times
cosine omega naught plus delta.
And if you if you
multiply the two signals,
your signal you are
interested in, or at least
you're interested
in one comportment,
you multiply it with
your local oscillator.
And then you
[? indicate ?] over time.
Then, of course, when you
peak the phase delta to be 0,
cosine omega t times
cosine omega [? dt ?]
gives cosine squared omega t.
It averages to 1/2.
So you would times average
where cosine omega t
times sine omega
t averages to 0.
So for delta equals
0, you project out
the cosine component.
And for delta equal
to 90 degrees,
you peak out the sine component.
So therefore, you can
have a measurement,
it's a phase
sensitive measurement,
by multiplying your signal with
the local oscillator, where
you're only sensitive to the
component you have squeezed.
And therefore, your
measurement uncertainty
has now been reduced by
the squeezing factor.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] only
that should be the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes,
actually, homodyne
means we use the same frequency.
Heterodyning would mean we
use two different frequencies.
But I'm not talking about that.
So we have to use exactly
the same frequency here.
AUDIENCE: So instead, this
[INAUDIBLE] oscillation
also needs a laser
to [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So, to address your question,
Angie, what usually happens
is you start with one
laser in those experiments.
You frequence the
top of the laser.
If you wanted to
do some squeezing,
you remember that we need a
parametric oscillator, where
one energetic photon
gives us two photons.
So what you do is you start
with a laser, [INAUDIBLE].
A 1064 nanometer.
You frequency double
it to green laser.
The green laser pumps your
parametric oscillator.
And then you get,
for down conversion,
you can squeeze light at 1064.
But this is because you
first stopper the laser.
And then you break the
photon into new pieces.
It has exactly the same
frequency as your laser
you started with.
And this laser is in the local
oscillator, or the reference
clock, for your
whole experiment.
So everything in your
experiment, the double laser,
the parametrically
down converted beams.
Everything is related to the
single laser you started with.
And everything is
phase coherent.
So that's how, usually,
the experiment is done.
Before I tell you what we're
doing quantum mechanically,
let me just also
get another question
out of the system, which I've
been asked several times.
People ask me,
well, the problem is
that the ellipse
rotates like this.
Isn't there a way--
now I need my hand--
that we can have an
ellipse rotating like this?
And that would be great.
But this is sort of unnatural
because the harmonic oscillator
does that.
So if you wanted to do that,
you need an operator which
is really, at every cycle of
the electromagnetic field,
is when the light want
to sort of do this.
No.
Always push it back.
And this is impractical.
You need, really, an oscillator
which would completely
change the quadrature components
of your harmonic oscillator
in every single cycle of
the electromagnetic field.
But sort of what homodyne
detection is, instead
of now forcing the light to
stay aligned to sort of do
this, which is
very unnatural, we
allow the light
to freely evolve.
But we have now an observer,
our local oscillator,
which is rotating
synchronously with the ellipse.
So we have a local oscillator
which is cosine omega t.
It does, so to speak, exactly
what the ellipse is doing.
So in that sense,
the local oscillator
allows us, now, to
observe the ellipse always
from its narrow side.
Because the local oscillator
is [? cooperating ?].
But the mathematics is
pretty much the [? Fourier ?]
transform.
The mathematics is a
[? Fourier ?] transform.
The physics is the physics
of a [INAUDIBLE] detector.
OK, now the only question
remaining is, how do we mix?
How do we get a
product of our signal
and the strong local oscillator?
In an old radio, it's
done by an element.
Maybe a diode, which
is a nonlinear circuit.
If you drive a nonlinear
element with two input sources,
you get something which
involves the product of the two.
OK, so the principal
of homodyne detection
is now that we want to mix
light at the beam splitter.
So the device which
does all that for us
is, after using so many
words, I would say it's
disgustingly simple.
It's really a half [INAUDIBLE].
We talked about
beam splitters a lot
here because beam
splitters perform
wonderful unitary
transformations.
And we'll exploit them
for many purposes.
For the purpose of
this lecture, I simply
assume that we have a
50-50 beam splitter.
So, what I'm telling you
now about the beam splitter
will be generalized.
Either later today, or in
the lecture on Wednesday.
So a beam splitter has two
input ports and output ports.
We have light impinging
on the beam splitter.
We call those modes a and b.
And after the beam splitter,
we have two output modes.
And let me call them a0 and b0.
And what we measure is the
output of the beam splitter.
So we have two photo detectors.
And we measure the output.
OK.
The output modes, a
naught and b naught,
are simply obtained by
taking the input modes
and propagating them.
We have two modes, a, b.
You can say, what
goes vertically is a.
Vertical is a.
We call it a naught.
Here, it's b.
It becomes b naught.
And what we have
to do is we have
two transform the
operator a naught.
Let me just make a comment.
Sometimes in the
beam splitter, you
want to think a quantum state
comes and is transformed.
But instead of transforming
the state of a photon,
I can also transform
the operator,
which creates a photon.
One is the Heisenberg picture.
One is a Schrodinger picture.
So right now, I'll use
the Heisenberg picture.
I have two operators, a, b.
Before the beam splitter is set,
I have two operators, a naught,
b naught.
Afterwards, I have
two other operators.
I have operators a, b.
Afterwards, i have operators
a naught, b naught.
And, if you do the
time evolution,
it's a unitary transformation.
And for operators, we have
to multiply the operators
from the left and
right hand side,
with unitary operator,
u and u dagger.
And we really talk
about the beam splitter
in its full beauty
in a short while.
It will be a special case
of what we discuss later.
But I think it's pretty obvious
that a 50-50 beam splitters is
simply creating two modes.
One of the symmetric
combination.
And one of the anti
symmetric combination.
OK.
So in our homodyne
detector, we are now
measuring the number of
photons in the mode a naught.
We measure with
the upper detector,
the number of photons
in the mode b naught.
But what we are then
doing is we run it
through a different [INAUDIBLE].
We want to cancel
certain noises,
as you will see in a moment.
This is why we
obtain the difference
signal, which we call I minus.
So let's now calculate
what I minus is.
Well, the number of photons
in the mode a naught
is a naught dagger a naught.
That's the operator for
the number of photons.
We subtract b naught
dagger b naught.
And, as you can
immediately see, is
that it because of the
beam splitter, this
is now involving a
product of a and b.
ab dagger plus a dagger b.
So in other words,
when you ask yourself,
how can we-- remember, I said
we peak out the cosine omega t
component by
multiplying our signal
with the local oscillator.
And you would say,
how do you multiply
two modes of the
electromagnetic field?
Well, just send it
to a beam splitter.
In a beam splitter, you
create the sum of them.
But then your photo detector
is square [INAUDIBLE] detector.
You measure the electric
fields squared or you
have to measure the
operator, a dagger a.
And now, you get the [INAUDIBLE]
between ab dagger and a dagger
b.
So this is how we
multiply two operators.
How we get a signal, which is
a proportional to a or a dagger
times b or b dagger.
By the way, if it wouldn't
take the difference,
we get terms of aa
dagger bb dagger.
Just the mode a or the
mode b by themselves.
And we want to get rid of them.
And by taking the difference
between the two photo
detectors, those parts of
the signal are becoming mode.
And are subtracted out.
So therefore, this is
called balanced homodyne
because we have the
balanced beam splitter.
We measure to two signals.
And then we take the
difference of the two signals.
OK.
There's one more
thing we have to add.
And then we find we understand
the balanced homodyne
detection.
We want to explore it.
That our mode b,
remember we want
to measure mode a. a squeezed.
a has quantum properties.
a has only single photons.
And b is just a trick to
project out the cosine omega t.
And we do that by choosing
for b a strong coherent state,
described by a coherent
state parameter beta.
Of course, whenever we have
a strong coherent state,
that means that we
can replace b by beta,
and b dagger by beta star.
This is sort of
the classical field
limit of a strong
coherent state.
And now we can ask, what this
our different signal I minus?
Well, the coherent state depends
on the phase angle theta.
So it will be phase sensitive.
It will depend on
the angle theta.
But now there is one more thing.
And that is, if you use a
stronger coherent state,
of course both of our outputs
go up in proportion to beta.
So therefore, we want
to go to a normalization
by dividing by beta.
So this is now our
normalized output.
I'm looking at this.
So this is our operator
for the signal I minus.
And that is a.
b has been replaced by, b dagger
has been replaced by b star.
That gives us a times
e to the-- because
of the complex
conjugation-- minus i
theta plus a dagger times e
to the i theta divided by 2.
So therefore, if we
choose the phase to be 0,
we measure this
symmetric combination,
a plus a dagger over 2.
And this is-- just
comparing notes--
simply the a1 quadrature
operator divided by square root
2.
And if you put a phase shifter,
just a dispersive element,
into the strong local
oscillator and shift
the phase by pi over 2, by
delaying the light pulse
by a quarter wavelength, what
we are now projecting out
is the other
quadrature component.
So therefore, using
the beam splitter
and the local
oscillator, we can now
measure the expectation
value for a1 and for a2.
I've posted a few papers
on the website which
show some of the pioneering
experiments where
people did exactly that.
So then, when they observed the
quadrature comportment, which
was squeezed, they usually
did it for a squeezed vacuum,
so a1 and a2 had 0
expectation value.
But the interesting part is,
how much noise was there?
If you don't squeeze, you find
that your normalized noise
simply corresponds to the
classical photon shot noise.
But if you are
squeezed, you find
that one quadrature
comportment has
a smaller noise than shot noise.
So [INAUDIBLE] photons
in your different signal.
And your noise is less
than square root n.
Where as in the
other quadrature,
the component is larger.
So you can look up
on the website papers
where people slowly varied the
phase of the local oscillator.
And you see, this
is shot noise, how
the noise is below shot noise.
Exceeds shot noise.
It's below shot noise.
And exceeds shot noise.
And this was the first
evidence for the generation
of squeezed light.
Questions?
OK.
So we have discussed
the detection
of squeezed light using
balanced homodyne detector.
And balanced means that the
beam splitter was 50-50.
So now we are ready to
discuss the unbalanced case.
So let's get our
unbalanced beam splitter
and, just for the
sake of the argument,
let's say it has a really
good transmission of tt.
So transmission
coefficient t squared
tells you what fraction of
the power is transmitted.
And let's just assume for
the sake of the argument, 99%
are transmitted.
So therefore, if we
start with our signal
a, which may be
[INAUDIBLE] squeezed
quantum state, number state.
You name it.
a naught is pretty
much the same as a.
We haven't lost so much.
But now we use our
local oscillator,
which is very strong.
Only a very small fraction
of it will be reflected.
But we can always compensate
for the small reflection
by making b even stronger.
Let's see what we get.
So the mode, a naught,
the output mode,
is now the transmission
coefficient times a.
a and a.
The operators are amplitudes.
So we have to use, if you
have a 99% beam splitter,
we have to take the
square root of 0.99.
This is the transmission
coefficient.
And now we have the
transmission coefficient
for the strong local
oscillator, which
we will again approximate
by its eigenvalue.
Coherent state eigenvalue.
And the reflection coefficient
is 1 minus t squared.
So if we make the approximation
that t is approximately 1,
we can take it out
off the parenthesis.
And we obtain that.
If t is close to 1,
we can neglect it.
And what we see now is
what we have obtained
is actually the original
quantum state a.
Or I should say.
The operator.
I'm in the Heisenberg picture.
a is the mode
operator for the input
of the unbalanced
homodyne detector.
And what we have simply done is
we have displaced the operator.
We have displaced
the mode operator a.
And the displacement operator
has an [? argument ?]
of 1 minus t squared beta.
And this is a
Hermitian conjugate.
1 minus t squared beta.
So what I've shown you here
is that the local oscillator
and the beam splitter is the
realization, or implementation,
of the displacement operator.
So in the limit that
t goes to unity,
we are not losing anything
of out quantum state.
But by reflecting
in the amplitude
of a strong coherent state, we
simply take our quantum state,
and we displace it in this
two dimensional plane.
So that's what this beam
splitter does for us.
Any questions?
In the next few
classes, we really
take advantage of
those elements.
We know now that the
displacement operator is just
a beam splitter.
We know when we have
squeezed some light
by using balanced
homodyne detection,
we can just do measurement
of one quadrature component
or the other.
So what I hope for those of
you who haven't heard about it,
what you take away
from that is that these
are extremely simple elements.
But by combining
them, we can really
realize very sophisticated
schemes of quantum optics.
To some extent, when I heard
about it for the first time,
I think, the mathematics
look so fancy.
I couldn't believe that such
simple elements can actually
realize what those
operators describe.
So I gave you the example for
the displacement operator.
When I learned about
the beam splitter,
and its underlying
physics, there
was one thing which
really fascinated me.
And this is the most simple
element you can think of.
I mean, what is simpler
than a beam splitter?
A beam splitter has two
inputs, two outputs.
The simplest optical element
is just an attenuator.
Put in a window
in your laser beam
and you lose 4% of
your power preserves.
Or put in just a little
bit of dirty optics
and you lose a few percent.
So what I want to
discuss with you now
is, what really is an
attenuator quantum mechanically?
Well if, classically,
the attenuator
would do the following.
An attenuator is a device
which has a transmission, which
is a transmission
coefficient squared,
which is smaller than unity.
And, in a classical system,
if you have a coherent state,
you would simply assume that the
coherent state gets multiplied
by the transmission coefficient.
In other words, that you
have your original state,
described by this
phase, or alpha.
And then, the action
of the attenuator
would simply be to
scale everything down
by a transmission
effect of alpha.
So the picture you should
have is the following.
You have a coherent state.
It gets attenuated by the
transmission coefficient.
But if there are fluctuations
about the coherent state,
also the fluctuations
get attenuated.
Because everything gets
attenuated by this attenuator.
So if you look at that, you
should immediately say, no.
This is quantum
mechanically forbidden.
Because a coherent state with
a minimum uncertainty state,
this shaded area cannot
be smaller than 1/2.
But here it has become smaller.
So what I've shown
to you here is
it's a violation of
quantum mechanics.
It would actually mean, let
me just give you the example.
It would mean that if-- yeah.
The coherent state
is quantum limited.
And if you calculate what is
the fluctuations in the photo
number, it's a shot noise.
So just to give you sort of
simple, intuitive example,
if you have 10,000 photons plus
minus 100, it's a shot noise.
Square root n.
If you could now attenuate
it by a factor of 100,
and you would go from
10,000 plus minus 100,
to 100 plus minus 1.
That's much better
than the shot noise.
I mean, this is what
I'm just telling you
what a simpleminded
attenuator would do.
And you would immediately say,
that's too good to be true.
I cannot get sub
shot noise light.
So what is wrong?
Impossible.
Not allowed.
Well, we've just tried
to formulate something
intuitively.
And we have to be careful.
Well, we know
already one way how
we can attenuate an input beam.
And maybe we should go back to
the situation and analyze it.
We know what if we can attenuate
it with a beam splitter.
And this beam splitter has a
transmission coefficient of t.
And then we get our
transmitted coherent light.
There is something
getting reflected.
But now we realize that
this beam splitter is not
just a device which
has one input.
It has another input.
And you may say, well, I don't
care about the other input.
I don't want to use it.
Well, if you don't
want to use the input,
it has the vacuum state.
So therefore, if you would
realize the attenuator
with the beam splitter, it
would mean that, in addition,
and this is what the math
really shows, in addition
to the attenuated coherent
state, which mathematically
is also attenuating
the fluctuations,
you have to add something.
Which is the
reflection coefficient
times the vacuum state.
Which is this.
And if you now
correctly do the math,
if you add the two
together, you find
you get a coherent state which
has an amplitude of t alpha.
But has the correct
[INAUDIBLE] fluctuation
is again a minimum
uncertainty state.
So the disk of your
attenuated state
hasn't exactly the same area
as the unattenuated state.
So I've shown you
the physical part.
I have shown you the
graphical solution.
The math is very simple.
But I really want you
to do the math yourself.
This is a new
homework problem we
designed to illustrate
the physics.
But what it tells
you is the following.
If you take a neutral
density filter out
of the lab [INAUDIBLE] and say,
this is not a beam splitter.
This is an attenuator.
Sorry.
You cannot simply attenuate
a quantum mechanical mode.
This is not a unitary
time evolution.
What you attenuate [INAUDIBLE]
is, without you knowing it,
it couples the electromagnetic
wave to whatever.
To the heat path
of the [INAUDIBLE],
which is in your attenuator.
I don't even want
to describe it.
But you're not
circumventing the limitation
of the beam splitter.
Whenever you attenuate,
whenever you have a laser beam,
and it undergoes losses,
when you send a laser beam
through the atmosphere, and
it undergoes some losses by,
who knows,
[INAUDIBLE] scattering
through the air or
something like this.
That means you get an
attenuated coherent state.
But you couple in the
fluctuations off the vacuum.
And this establishes
shot noise now,
at the lower level of intensity.
So your attenuator is not
a single state device.
Dissipation.
Attenuation really
means you connect
with other parts of
[INAUDIBLE] space.
You cannot attenuate in a
small part [INAUDIBLE] space.
This is impossible.
This is not unitary
time evolution.
So what I've just told you
has dramatic consequences
for any form of non
classical, or squeezed, light.
And that's the following.
Most of you are
experimentalists.
And you know that when you run
a laser at one or two watts,
you send it through optics, and
shudders, and optical fibers.
How much do you get at the
end of your experiment?
Not even 50%.
So, whenever you create
light, and then you
want to do something, you
lose some of the light.
And let's now assume that
you have done what was really
a breakthrough in scientific
headlines within your lifetime.
You have generated
squeezed light.
And now we want to use
the squeezed light.
Shine it on atoms and do
a precision measurement,
which is better than the
standard quantum limit
because you have
squeezed the ellipse.
And you want to now exploit
the sharpness of the ellipse.
What happens to your
aspect ratio of the ellipse
when your beam is attenuated?
So let me just discuss
it with you graphically.
So let's assume we
have a squeezed state.
And we send it through
an optical fiber.
The result is you will
never send a squeezed state
through an optical fiber.
But I want you to realize that.
So let's assume we have our
squeezed state, symbolized
by that.
Let's use some red
color for the state.
And now, in the
time evolution, we
have some [INAUDIBLE]
scattering.
Some fiber absorption.
But you know already,
the absorption
is in reality a beam splitter,
which happens in the vacuum.
So
We have now some finite
transmission coefficients.
And that would mean,
which is the bad news,
that your ellipse gets shrunk.
It shrinks.
It shrinks by the
transmission factor t.
But that's what I did bad.
You lose some of your power.
But the really bad thing
is that if I multiply it
with the reflection coefficient,
you couple in the vacuum.
Oops.
I'm going to change to red.
And, as a result, since
the noise in the vacuum
is equal in both
quadrature components,
you've worked so hard to squeeze
it, to make it asymmetric.
But what you get now
is from your ellipse,
you get something which is
much more egg shaped now.
So in other words, you can
write it down with operators.
But once you understand
what is going on,
you immediately realize that
losses reduce the squeezing.
And this is a challenge to
all the experiments using
squeezed or non classical light.
And you see how
the scaling works.
If you have squeezed your
ellipse by a factor of 100,
even 1% of the vacuum
will spoil your squeezing.
So the more you have
squeezed, the more
non-classical the light is--
the more valuable it is.
The more sensitive it is,
to even very small losses.
Questions?
OK, good.
Now we have 10 more minutes.
What I want to do now
is, I want to show you
that the language
which we have used,
the methods we have introduced,
can now be used for something
which is really
cool-- teleportation.
I want to show you how
balanced homodyne detection,
quadrature measurement, and
displacement operator can
be put together to
generalize is scheme which
is a scheme for
teleporting quantum states.
This is an application
of squeezing, homodyning,
and all that.
Teleportation of light.
Let me just illustrate
what the problem is.
I know we have only
10 minutes, and I've
decided not to write down
all the math for you.
I went, actually, to
the Wikipedia page,
and corrected a few
mistakes in the equations
and edited a few explanations.
I think you can just sit
down and read it by yourself.
What I want to
explain to you, here,
is the physical concepts
behind teleportation,
and you the crucial steps
to realize teleportation.
So first, what is teleportation?
Well, teleportation has
a sender and a received,
which in quantum
information science
are called Alice and Bob.
Teleportation means Alice
has a quantum state, psi.
And she wants to send this
quantum state, psi, to Bob.
In other words, you have,
maybe, some squeezed light.
You have something--
a quantum state,
psi-- which is interesting.
And the question is, how can
Bob create an identical copy
of this quantum
state, psi, that he
can sort of [INAUDIBLE]
with the same quantum state.
Before you appreciate
teleportation,
you have to realize
what the problem is.
The problem is, really,
in fundamental properties
of quantum systems,
fundamental limitations-- what
you can do with
a quantum system.
First, I have to tell you
what is allowed, and what not.
In this game, teleportation
means, of course,
you will not take your atom and
your photons in the state psi,
just propagate them to
Bob, and Bob has them.
That's trivial.
I can send any
quantum state to you
by transmitting an atom
or a laser beam to you,
and you have the same
quantum state I had earlier.
This is not teleportation.
This is trivial propagation.
What is meant is that we don't
have a quantum channel-- I'm
not allowed to send my
quantum state to you.
But in teleportation, I can do
a measurement on the quantum
state, call you up through
a classical communication
channel, and tell you, the
result of my measurement
is such and such.
And then you would say, well,
if I have a spin system,
and I measure spin up--
I call you and say,
my measurement was spin up, and
you create a spin up system.
Isn't that teleportation?
The answer is no, because
maybe the state I had
was a superposition
of spin up and down.
And what I measured
is only spin up.
And by telling you
it's spin up, you
would never create a
superposition state,
you would just create
a spin up state.
So the effect is, that if I
do a measurement on my quantum
state, and report
my results to you,
you have insufficient
information.
Because a projective
measurement on a quantum
state inevitably leads
to loss of information.
A measurement on a
single quantum state
does not create
enough information
to recreate the quantum state.
Of course, there is
an obvious solution.
When we want to obtain
information about a quantum
state, we often, in
quantum mechanics,
have to do many measurements.
And we can take a
spin state, we can
measure what is
its x, what its y,
what is the c
component of the spin.
We can completely
characterize the spin state,
and then we know
everything about it.
But the problem is, we have
only one quantum state,
and we can't do
repeated measurements.
Then you would say, well, the
next thing is, why don't you
just take your quantum
state and Xerox it,
make many, many copies.
And then you have
an ensemble, and you
can take as many
measurements you want.
You can do an x
measurement, p measurement.
I mean, you can reconstruct
the complete wave function.
You can measure with an x basis.
You can measure with
a momentum basis.
You can collect all
the information.
But the problem is-- otherwise
the whole teleportation
would not be an
issue at all-- there
is the no-cloning theorem.
You cannot duplicate
a quantum state.
If you have an atom in a certain
quantum state and another atom,
it is quantum-mechanically
forbidden--
there is no unitary
transformation,
no way of creating a
situation that you have
one unknown quantum
state, plus another atom,
or another light beam,
and after some interaction
you have two times the
same quantum state.
You cannot clone.
Therefore, based on all that, we
cannot clone the quantum state.
We are only left
with the one copy
of the quantum state,
which Alice has.
Alice is not allowed
to send it to Bob.
Maybe Bob is on the
other side of the ocean,
or on another planet.
All what Alice can do is,
she can do one measurement
and tell Bob, this
is my measurement.
So this is the problem
of teleportation.
How is that possible?
Well, the way how I put
it, it seems impossible.
But there's a way out of it.
Let me just write
down what I said.
So the goal is now-- Alice
performs measurement,
reports result to Bob.
And now, Bob will recreate
the quantum state.
What I've just said is, to
perform a single measurement
is not enough information.
So this is not enough.
We need one more resource.
And the resource,
which is now used
to use quantum teleportation,
is that you take some entangled
system, or-- and this why I talk
about it today-- or squeezed
light.
That's the same thing.
It's a form of entanglement.
I told you that when we
generate squeezed light
with a parametric
down conversion,
the parametric down conversion
takes a green photon
and creates two identical
infrared photons.
Until now, we have
discussed that
those identical
infrared photons go
into the same mode,
which is squeezed.
But now, a slight
extension of this concept
would mean, in parametric
down conversion,
you squeeze something, but
one photon goes to Alice,
one photon goes to Bob.
So now, Alice and Bob have
an additional resource.
They sort of own--
each of them-- half
of the two twin brothers,
which are the photons created
in the parametric down
conversion process.
And that will work.
So the idea is the following.
To create those twin
beams of photons
is simply done with an
optical parametric oscillator.
There is one extension, which
is described on the Wiki.
I won't have time to
explain it to you.
But it's a two-mode OPO.
It puts the two identical
photons-- not in the same beam,
as we did before, we had
the a dagger squared,
a squared operator-- they
go into two different modes.
You know the magic of
beam splitters by now.
Now, two beams come out.
One goes to Alice,
one goes to Bob.
If Alice would take her input
state-- this unknown state
which is handed to her
by Victor, somebody
else who participates in
the game-- we know already,
if Alice would
perform a measurement,
the quantum state
would be destroyed.
The result of the measurement--
let's talk about spin-1/2--
would only be one
spin projection.
It's not enough to
reproduce a state.
But what she is doing
is, she uses, again,
the magic of the beam splitter.
So one of those
twin brother photons
is now mixed with
the unknown quantum
state at the beam splitter.
And the output of
the beam splitter
is now entering the
balanced homodyne detection,
which we just discussed.
The output of this beam
splitter-- and there
are two outputs--
both of them is now
becoming part of a balanced
homodyne measurement.
And you see the ingredients.
So this, and this,
will be measured.
The other input for
the balanced homodyne
is a strong local oscillator.
The phase of the
local oscillator
is chosen, in one case, that you
measure the x or a 1 quadrature
component, or the p
or the a 2 component.
So now what Alice
has done is, by using
this balanced
homodyning, she has--
with this local
oscillator-- has actually
now performed two measurements.
The quantum state is destroyed,
but here she gets an x value,
and here she gets a p value.
So how the magic works out.
It's really just a few
lines of mathematics, now.
These were sort of, you
know, twin brothers.
But it wasn't clear
in which quantum
state the twin brothers are.
If you write it
down, and I can show
you the formula in a moment,
these are twin brothers.
But those twin brothers-- this
is Brother 1, this is Brother
2-- are in sort of a
continuum of states.
And when Alice this would
measure that this twin brother
is in state big X, that would
be a projective measurement.
And Bob's twin brother
would now, with certainty,
also be in the state, X.
So therefore, what happens
is, the measurement of x and p
is now producing-- is now,
through the measurement
process-- putting the other
photon, or the other beam,
the other twin brother, into
a specific quantum state.
And if you look for
few lines of math,
the magic is that the quantum
state-- which is now here,
with Bob-- turns out
to be a displaced copy
of the original state.
And the displacement
depends on x and p.
So if Alice now tells Bob,
hey, I measured x and p,
and Bob is now [INAUDIBLE]
his displacement operator--
remember, a
displacement operator is
nothing else than an
unbalanced beam splitter,
with a huge local
oscillator as an input.
So if Bob is now setting up
his displacement operator,
it makes a displacement
which depends on x and p.
He can take this other twin
brother, shift it back,
and he will exactly
regenerate the quantum
state which Alice had.
So this is, now,
how a quantum state
can be transmitted
without having any quantum
channel for transmission.
You're not propagating
the quantum state.
You use classical communication,
but the resource you use
is some EPR pairs,
or squeezed light.
It's a few lines
of equations, but I
don't have time
to go through it.
They're really
annotated in a way
that I think it will be an
enjoyful reading for you.
Any questions?
Time is over.
OK.
A reminder for those who
came late-- this week
we have three classes,
Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
Have a good afternoon.